former defense secretary donald rumsfeld
has died at the age of 88.
rumsfeld was both the youngest and the
oldest person
ever to lead the department he served in
that role twice
first under president gerald ford and
then in the george w
bush administration david martin covered
rumsfeld
throughout his career and has more from
the pentagon
an aide described donald rumsfeld as a
force of nature
a military adviser once wore his flak
jacket to a meeting with the famously
harassable secretary of defense
he was there to shake the place up as he
told me on cbs sunday morning
change is hard for people change is hard
but did you make it
harder than it had to be by alienating
people if you don't want to change and
someone above you wants to it's it's not
fun
then on 9 11 it was war when the plane
plowed into the pentagon rumsfeld ran
toward danger to help pull the wounded
from the rubble
later aides urged him to evacuate but he
refused
this is a a tragic day for our country
those briefings made him the public face
of first the war in afghanistan
and then iraq his wife joyce watched
with amusement
relaxed and then the minute i mean
if you think that phased me it didn't at
all
do you know because you know it will end
which happened when the lightning march
to baghdad turned into what rumsfeld
called a long hard slog
then pictures of american guards abusing
iraqi prisoners came to light
the worst day was was abu ghraib and
seeing that that what went on there and
and feeling
so uh deeply sorry that
that that that happened president bush
fired rumsfeld
by then he had been a congressman
ambassador white house chief of staff
and secretary of defense
not once but twice he was as richard
nixon said
a different cup of tea for cbs this
morning
david martin the pentagon